all voice is it a guy trapped in the
room yeah yeah basically it had a twist
they created it can be painfully rare to
end up in a satisfying conversation a
lot of the time we talk and we listen
but sincere deep connection eludes us
oil yes and pan its react differently
and more healthy or less I like rapeseed
oil is actually really I like that I
misspoke we shouldn't blame ourselves
for the difficulties we face in
conversations after all no one ever
particularly taught us how to have a
conversation though it might have helped
this is the slot the orbital is the
other one besides all that set it of 40
what as people trying to get to work
being trying to get to school
which so it's just so stupid too often
when we meet and talk we stay on the
surface of events we say what happened
where we went who we saw not how we felt
or what it meant to us we talk about
facts not feelings which are the only
conduits to real connection thing that's
the issue it's like when you're on that
platform you see there's Royston nature
of Garden City and well in Garden City
and that's the thing like a lot of
people are there on that platform awake
they don't know that they could change
your Alexandra Palace or else we insist
rather than explain feelings there by
failing to get them into other people's
minds like so amazing I still cut a lot
even thinking of it now is just like ah
ah you know the yeah you know when
you're kind of oh god it was great fast
so good
typically we skirt the raw and intense
emotions and head for safe but bland
administrative chat why you seat me and
then obviously when the engines break up
and I became vegetarian I have found
just absolutely the most amazing recipe
book
it's literally I don't know if you've
seen it and it's got like you can
replace sort of the the dish that you
would have with me in it or else we
simply can't keep a conversation on
track we repeatedly as it were open new
windows digressing until the threat is
law
so the thing you actually think of
playing poker this weekend with you know
my mates but I don't play anymore
because the mustard money last year and
I don't so much to read now I'm more
interested in reading if anything but it
goes black I am going skiing next week
so bad day is not kind of place you
might read but the good news is that we
can learn to shape other's conversations
rather than just receive them passively
in a dialogue there are always what one
might term conversational crossroads
with paths that lead either to greater
intimacy or else towards ongoing
superficiality here is one
conversational crossroads I'm inviting
some friends over next week who I
haven't seen since uni at this point you
could go in one of two ways
a surface way oh cool what what
university did you go to me oh yeah it's
really fun Manchester yeah my sister at
night what did you study business what
what what did you do in the second half
for well I ended up in Events Management
but yeah I did French oh you could steer
things down a more emotional path I'm
inviting some friends over next week who
I haven't seen since uni oh my gosh it's
like what 10 12 years yeah that's when
open it might got my degree here so I
mean you've all completely changed I
mean you've changed yeah I guess I have
here supposed to really thought about it
that much what would you think or say I
mean if you could see you then now good
listeners are like good editors trimming
away what's superfluous trying gently to
get the speaker to focus on what's
really at stake and after my mum died as
you can probably guess there's quite a
bit of stress well I a lot helped by the
fact that my favorite football team at
the time and just United was going
through a losing streak so but you were
saying that like your parents got
divorced and then literally three months
later one passed away yes it was all
quite quite quick yeah but yeah I've got
a friend Dave um or David as he's called
him work because obviously I was very
informal thanks Pete in mine you were
saying like it just like it all happened
really quickly and like when your mum
went to us we didn't actually know she
was ill before
the other great surprise about
conversations is how much we like it
when people show vulnerability we always
think that what we need to do to get
other people to like us is to show how
well things are going for us
surprisingly that's actually not very
appealing it's so well paid and which is
great in terms of you know now I can
afford you know to live in Canterbury
and which is gorgeous
and I love my flat and so yeah it's been
really really positive actually it's not
that we want others to fail we just need
to know that our own sorrows have echoes
in the lives of others that's what
connects us strength may be impressive
but its vulnerability that builds
friendships yes I guess so mr. every day
since then which is mad because you know
I'm a grown man now got a responsible
job the family got my own home but when
it comes down to it let's just miss
Milan it's so poignant that we make so
much effort to come together but often
don't manage to connect the good news is
we can learn how to the connections we
long for are just waiting for us to make
the right moves to secure them we
believe in making the world a more
emotionally intelligent place and to
that end we've now also published some
extraordinary books as well as other
merchandise that reinforces some of the
themes illustrated in our videos please
click on the link below to see more